hello we are alive
right yeah we're
alive
uh so what the hell am I doing playing
Magic at 300
pm on a
weekday uh so here's the
thing here's the
thing uh I've had meetings all freaking
week long I've gotten a few Dev things
done on the side a a few pretty good Dev
things done on the side uh but I have
more yet more meetings later in the
evening today uh and these meetings
involve reinforcement learning and Magic
which I've actually never played I've
played a couple of different card
games but uh I have not ever played
magic and we are looking at building
like a card game type SIM for puffer lib
so I figured I have to play this before
those meetings uh other so I'm just not
completely stupid I've watched a lot of
content around this and other card games
and since I've had basically no time to
stream much Dev this week I figured I'd
stream this because why the hell not and
I'll answer random RL stuff along the
way but I just want to figure out what's
going on so I understand that there are
lands